do you think that they have like do
black guys from America look differently
at black guys that come like say like
there's a guy from Jamaica or there's a
guy from like Zaire who just moved to
America what's that relationship oh man
that's when black guys feel white you
know say yeah
I don't know what type of races that
don't say well with somebody say which
black guy which black guy you want to
date whatever you got one say me they
were like it is me over here and Deborah
always it's a tough one it's a tough one
you don't say that's a tough that's why
man because sometimes it's like yeah I'm
like those types of people those black
people from Africa are so different I'd
like them black people from America you
know yeah the go girls the other
hustlers for sure yeah their husbands
but it's funny like you if without
without hearing a black person when you
see him you have an instant connection
with them yeah you don't saying do you
know you do yeah yeah you all you know
you like oh that's my [ __ ] right yeah
yeah
but then when I talk like this like this
who are you calling a [ __ ] yeah but
just on the first look on skin whatever
you have like a instant connection well
yeah that's cool man yep I get nervous
um do you want to be black son you ever
thought about it oh yeah I've thought
about it yeah when I was like you know
from age you know 12 to 16 every white
kid does you know so then I definitely
did but now I think I would want to be
Mexican next I think for me black still
seemed a little too risky I would wait
one more another year before you double
another cycle like another life cycle
all right like reincarnated one time be
Latino and there was this D now just Dan
black or risky big black like unit
chorus it's still too risky for me I get
nervous a lot I know I have fear and
anxiety
yeah yeah yeah if you get nervous now
you wouldn't be good black yeah nah
definitely couldn't have no traffic stop
dude do black people get nervous because
it always seemed like to me when I was
growing up I honestly don't know that
black people never got I was like [ __ ]
black people do not get nerve now we do
procedure we use different language like
you call it nervous and then
we might call it shook right you don't
say like he was nervous now I was it's
the same definition where were you
nervous now I was just a little shook
yeah I mean we just don't identify with
certain things like when it comes to uh
like depression yeah white people can
identify with depression anxiety posts
whatever pros yeah that's just they
could deal with that you know saying but
you have a white person are you stressed
yeah I'm really stressed you stress
blackbirds like nine stress I'm just a
little [ __ ] up right is the word you
use you know I've said and I know like
like Charlemagne the guy has his book
cause [ __ ] one and he was talking about
disfigure more black people dealt with
mental issues and he's as a person he
said from presidents ban a therapist
$100 our to talk to him about promise
yeah that was black person from the hood
can't afford a therapist right good for
is a bag we yeah a bottle of Hennessy
and that's what we look through that's
how we get get we deal with mental it's
not the way it should be but we don't
use the same words because you get
different drugs you don't say when you
say when you say I'm a little stressed
out anxiety you get prozac xanax and all
that type [ __ ] if you say that to a
black person you get wheat so I might
try to give you a loan and blow you're
saying is that it's not the right thing
to do but it's just different
definitions I say you know oh that's and
all of us below [ __ ] that right now but
the whole thing about being a little
[ __ ] right now is how you cook with
think coping is is none what they have
to deal with with any mental issues can
you cope with it yeah do they have like
unique mental issues that you think
black guys get that white guys don't get
I don't know if this is a mental issue
but a lot of black guys give a white
guys can't well they can but like jungle
fever yeah you know saying I don't think
that that's a mental disorder but it's
something it's something that's a little
taboo in the black community so is it
scary would you bring a white girl home
to like a black Thanksgiving never I
tried out I tried that once before and I
guess I feel scared almost even thinking
about I wouldn't do that because I did
it one time I wear this white chick home
for Thanksgiving and the family there
was a tall you know you
his love and and she showed up to
Thanksgiving with a Tater Tot Casserole
and she showed up with white people
potato salad yeah and potato salad the
ingredients were apples raisins cinnamon
yeah race itself I dare hope but yeah
yeah no no cholesterol you know I mean
if black people really get upset if you
bring the wrong potato salad so I
wouldn't advise bringing a white chick
home for Thanksgiving Christmas is
nothing but Thanksgiving it's a lot of
pressure it is yep
dude so I always had these weird
theories you know man and like I don't
think I'm racist like I think I first
saw up any time someone start this
sentence off what I don't think I'm it's
a little bit but you got types of raises
the type that people understand and it's
the type to get you [ __ ] up so what
which one were you dealing with I think
there was moments when our races are you
[Laughter]
know what time do you think I am the one
I'm trying to be honest about my racism
and try to get in so I can learn about
it and learn from it you know I think I
was I probably was more I definitely am
more racial anger towards black people
when I was younger probably growing up
or ignorance because ignorance ignorance
is the is the is the breeding ground for
races right when you're ignorant
president leads you in a situation where
you could be racist right I'm sad I may
not be fair I think mom was fear like
cuz I knew some dudes were ignorant I
knew dude you drove around and like you
know [ __ ] black people you know n-word
this and I wasn't that you know and my
mother wasn't that and my father wasn't
that like you know so but I would get
like you know there was just always you
know like I wrote on the bus with the
black kids to school so it was like I
don't the poor kid I don't know you know
so where was that the front of the back
of the bus this is goodness um well I
stayed in the middle I stayed right in
the back is where we keep it just set
the front so yeah the fun people the
people like myself spitballs airplane
back and like people that would few
didn't know which way to go said in the
middle yeah I said in the middle man I
was scared but I would get like you know
black kids were like there was like you
know kids would fight the black his role
was like stronger and tougher so I felt
like they were like if there was fights
they would always win the fights and so
I think I just had a lot more fear
probably about you know got jumped a
couple times like yeah so I think I had
more fear but then also had just as many
like buddies that were black because
they were loose like me like their
parents were they were doing whatever
they wanted just with a bike and just
rock yeah but if you got beat up but I
don't care what color person it was I
went racist yeah like if I got jumped in
age of 12 by whole bunch of Asians I
would never watch a comedy for the rest
of my life so I got a sour Joe now
whatever race beats you up with your
[ __ ] so I think it just made me scared
right but I think there's also this
thing I felt like but like you wanted
this this is obsession with black
culture that people want to be they want
to relate to it so much it's cool if you
go to any other country whatever the
people that they emulate the most
especially like hip-hop is black culture
yeah I don't know it is I don't know
that it goes back to you know when black
folks were all you know black folks were
always in entertainment I don't know
where it comes from but for some reason
people are curious about that lifestyle
yeah well knowing two black friends is
better than having [ __ ] cable these
days
yeah but as far as entertainment goes
knowing to just spending time with you
know black people like to laugh more
they like to there's just more [ __ ]
going on they right now somebody that
got shot like this just like I laughed
harder harder let you do it you do it
I'm a black comedy club you know what
they like yeah you know if you get oh
[ __ ] this bubble yo yo yo yo yo yo yo
stop it they let you fill it yeah and
it's so weird because I came up from the
black circuit you know right so I'm used
to people do when I do my shows if you
rip it you can feel it did I start doing
the main street across over so and I
started doing white rooms and then some
time it was hard to tell because you'll
get a chuckle
they'll point to you like this no that's
funny oh that's a great game yeah thumbs
up and like I couldn't understand I
would do shows
I get on stage I was like I hate that
[ __ ] they've kind of like this oh my god
you [ __ ] killed the way you set up
and the premise and the callback geez
I'm like I don't want you to break down
comedy [ __ ] I want you to laugh
and also a black community in a black
carbon club you have the joke haters
yeah the [ __ ] just angry
yeah Joe Gators they almost like you to
quit joking it's left like this
you know you'll say some funny [ __ ] they
like you good you good you was funny
but you was a funny funny funny funny a
white people white people when they like
you they [ __ ] do get on the Yelp
report yeah do the comment cards if you
look at a comment card at a me copy Club
there's never gonna be your sky bird I
mean there's never gonna be a Johnson or
Smith [ __ ] that calmness Tomica why
people like oh my god they leave
comments and they always sign up for the
email yeah
always why people are everybody's
guestbook sign when the show is already
like armed I noticed you didn't mention
anything about you guessable
is there a place where I can sign up for
your newsletter black people just like
how did you know about a [ __ ] told who
told you about the chonta streets [ __ ]
the streets you miss when you see um do
you like sometimes what I miss like old
school black guys like now it seem like
a lot of the black guys are like a
little softer like a little bit like I
saw a black eye with glasses the other
day like you'll see it's nothing wrong
with you know that's so disrespectful
son there's nothing wrong with the
glasses
everybody is some party like probably
wear glasses now the disrespectful
[ __ ]
you always gotta let you think is this
level of intellect when they just keep
pushing it up oh yeah I hate the ones
that like enforce a prayer like like let
me taste yeah and if those people in
glasses but you shouldn't you know just
because a black person wear glasses I
don't think you should for me any other
pin you know about them because of that
[ __ ] got a read bro yeah you
know I miss real fun I feel like it was
it seemed like there was just different
black kids when I was growing up then
there are now you know like they had a
black guy with the other day with asthma
that I met and that [ __ ] [ __ ] y'all
every blabbers I knew growing up and
grown up had asthma really yo when you
live in the projects with metal you can
have some respiratory issues do you
gotta go to Cleveland anywhere New York
glam pipe [ __ ] you as my yo-yo fairies
are smoking Newports in the bathroom you
gonna have an asthma pump that's what
you want no real big oh not as mad as
[ __ ]
well your asthma had better have some
asthma around his [ __ ] side do we had a
girl named asthma Wilson two in our
junior high
what about asthma allergies yeah who
said he was feeling dizzy bro yo
I'll tell you man they have allergies
wipe your calories and make the colleges
be known I'm gonna get on a flight now
without so why person stopping me from
getting artistic bag of peanuts man give
its mother [ __ ] train brah
you don't say hey guys hey 300 people um
Michael Michael Michael heard in which
I'm not white as day has an allergy
problem to peanuts so now nobody get
peanuts get the [ __ ] out of here with a
mallet that man but what about this
though you are he do um when I was young
like now they have more it seemed like
black diseases like when I was young
they had diabetes was popular that still
strong blood pressure right that's just
wrong it would out but now there's other
stuff you know it's like other you know
there's a black I had chicken pox I
remember your ass [ __ ] what is
that it was in Vietnam yeah yo you co
get chickenpox in the United States yo
yo yo your health care is not upside
that [ __ ] is only posed to be Africa and
muhfucka Haiti at Tyler's and you should
not be able to get chickenpox in America
but I'm just saying black people are
getting like weak diseases that used to
be only white people we get it seems
like that's something you know like the
only black disease not known isn't it's
it's gonna always stay in this test the
time is the itis yeah you know every I
think every black person I've ever went
school were to grow with all had the
itís what is it the itis is um it's the
it's like autism now itís is something
like you know like in the black
community where okay let's say you eat a
lot of food you get I want to go yeah
you know I'm saying that white people
have a name for doing Thanksgiving it's
something that's released in Turkey
tryptophan tryptophan trip to see in a
white guy knew it was a glad you like
now know what you say it you know but
that's one disease is very very strong
the black going to be a cure for what
relaxes the itis yeah when you get the
itis know like when you eat a lot and
then you feel yeah you usually get it
from stuff like like like like steaks
yeah cheeseburger ribs ribs if you eat
ribs it's like that's like you and you
inducing you make it happen to yourself
yeah but black people gonna have had the
ideas for years and probably continue to
have eyes and I know that I'm I know
that uh Reverend Al Sharpton's at a
point is like he's a vegan right now so
he really yeah he's a food is that how
do y'all treat that that seems not like
a black thing in a black community we
think I noticed it so [ __ ] up if you
vegan we think you get to say yeah you
don't say and I playing no again I feel
you and I can be like just change in
your diet yeah you could be fabulous all
homophobic like change your diet could
cause someone laugh you know I'm saying
go to like a hamburger spot with a black
dude and you order your cheeseburger
with like blue Allah would like Swiss
cheese or cottage cheese baby they'll be
they'll be on that cottage cheese Swiss
cheese blue cheese if you order blue
cheese and if you want cheese arrested
gateway drug to dick but they'll be on a
that's a gateway
didn't fall out yo this [ __ ]
chain sir I just caught this
[ __ ] eat new for the burger
cheese not that he chose it better
cheese but I caught him eating you down
you don't put mayonnaise on your burger
you gonna be some and you don't gotta
answer
you gotta answer to the street yeah is
that the life you want if that's what
that's the perception what people have
of you did you eat burgers with Swiss
cheese and cottage cheese crumbles
groans bruh
straight-up crafts Deluxe all day
represent Brooklyn you know that's just
it you know what's crazy as my sister
can't even read but what does it have to
do with us right now hope you enjoyed
that video and you can watch another and
you can watch this one you can watch
this one
different options different choices some
guy just brings you one option not this
guy
two options watch one this one